[Musica]
[Risate]
ora si è pervenuti
noi ci occupiamo
parole
e anche questa sera qui corre comunque
tour un viaggio
sotto la parola
composta a turbare
cornici la tua l'idea di qualcosa che
continua dall'interazione anche perché
noi siamo abituati a utilizzare la
parola spia o come l'ultimo respiro
lo diciamo con la persona e sospirata e
invece eppure per tre che ci da l'idea
del respiro del tv di qualcosa che
continua l'esperto è detto che
probabilmente non ci accorgiamo perché
lo facciamo sempre
occupata per tutta la vita
pensate che il corso di federica
pellegrini dice che noi respiriamo circa
20mila volte al giorno ma non ce ne
rendiamo conto però se pensa a quante
volte utilizzato nel 4 quotidiano delle
espressioni che riguardano il respiro
probabilmente capiamo che qualcosa di
profondamente
interiorizzato pensiamo ma cosa diciamo
non un attimo di respiro perché siamo
troppo impegnati oppure quando diciamo
qualcosa di più ampio respiro
[Musica]
oppure ancora quando siamo
emozionati diciamo mi manca il respiro
questo cosa significa
significa che noi del respiro ci
rendiamo conto
prevalentemente quando cambia perché
siamo nazionali perché il respiro cambia
in base alle nostre azioni
quindi se noi diciamo mi manca il
respiro perché siamo troppo emozionati è
perché evidentemente ci siamo resi conto
del fatto che il respiro
ea dircelo a insegnarcelo e anche dante
alighieri
questa per cena che vedete alle nostre
spalle ci dice che il giorno il 1300 in
qualche modo si chiamava il respiro lo
si cercava di descrivere con immagini
dante nel canto ventiquattresimo
dell'inferno dice la lena vera del
polmone si punta quando io fui io non
poteva più oltre al sì ma assisi nella
prima città ebbene la lena e il respiro
quindi dante usa un'immagine
l'immagine di questo respiro che quando
è corto quando è affannato immaginiamo
dante che probabilmente stava salendo
non una salita ed era affannato lo
vedremo anche più avanti
paragona il respiro che scivola via alla
mammella diciamo così di una di una
mucca quando il latte viene munto dante
poteva semplicemente dire mi mancava il
respiro invece scegliere un'immagine per
sottolineare proprio la valenza e il
valore del nostro respiro che del cuore
sapere il respiro abbiamo visto né
accennava prima mano
podere tanti significati e si comporta
un po come le parole lo vedremo più
avanti dante addirittura immedesima la
parola il verbo parlare con il verbo
respirare e il respiro si comporta come
le parole linguistica si dice che una
parola o significante e significato
il significante a indirla apparenza
della parola composta dalle lettere il
significante è uno solo i significa che
invece possono essere molteplici
questo perché perché ogni parola ma il
significato è la stessa cosa vale per il
nostro respiro quando noi respiriamo in
maniera moderata perché siamo in qualche
modo emozionato perché ci sta capitando
qualcosa anche in relazione al contesto
che ci sta davanti
avverte significati diversi
quindi il nostro respiro ha una valenza
narrativa
è un tutt'uno sono respiro strettamente
connesso alla parola se noi ci pensiamo
alla nostra colazione la comunicazione
all estero vale attraverso la voce non
esiste
noi parliamo perché siamo capaci di
respirare quindi parliamo perché così
respiro sono strettamente cortese e ce
lo dice benissimo
dina thomas lin questa questi una poesia
che dice questo dice che dalle nebulosi
basi praticamente del bel respiro
il tempo è arrivato dice dylan thomas e
dalle nebulose basi del respiro il verbo
ex lui
ma dicendo al cuore primi caratteri di
nascita e di modi quindi è tra le basi
del respiro che persona ma noi non
possiamo far bene per parlare comunicare
ma io spio non è soltanto parola può
essere anche una pausa nel respiro e
quello che abbiamo da sempre una
partitura musicale i silenzi sono quello
che alla fine fa del rating se ci
pensiamo le pause all'interno della
musica sono importantissime così come
pato riparliamo una pausa
quello quindi il nostro silenzio e
quello che a volte da più espressività
una parola questa è la citazione di
penna d'arianna che ci dice questo dice
in cui si e silenzi hanno lo stesso
ruolo che in musica sono una
respirazione
ma sono anche l'ombra delle parole boy
torri il es la miacard acea che ha fatto
una pausa serve a farci comprendere
meglio oppure andare più peso alle
parole cruciani e questo era bravissimo
da che abbiamo già citato di qui di
questi giorni proprio sono i 700 anni
dalla dipartita
dante era capace di utilizzare questa
parola maniera meraviglioso
entriamo proprio nella divina commedia
ogni 700 anche dalla scomparsa di dante
dante diverse volte padre nel risveglio
uno fa della divina commedia lo fa anche
nella vita nuova dice è come quel che
con lena affannata uscito fuori dalle
belle angolana riva si svolge dall acqua
perigliosa e cosa così l'animo miniot
ancor sfuggiva si volse al retro a
rimirar lo passo che non lasciarsi amare
persona viva
siamo all'inizio dell'inferno date è
appena uscito dalla selva oscura quella
che non lasciò giammai persona viva non
perché chirurgo rientrasse ulisse ma
perché nessuna anima viva nessuna
persona libera mai aveva mai
attraversato la selva oscura e pure
dante per dirci che era stanco affannato
utilizza un immagine utilizza un respiro
ben preciso quello del naufrago dante ci
sta di certo che qualsiasi situazione
che in qualche modo abbia un equilibrio
precario o comunque compromesso falso un
respiro e quindi dante sa che il
naufrago in qualche modo un respiro
diverso da quello dell'innamorato e
quindi tante cosa fanno
utilizza questa figura quest'immagine
per dire come si sentiva aveva il
respiro del nav è ancora dice siamo nel
paradiso in di spiro quello spirò non
significa quindi morì significa parlo
dante il medesimo i verbi parlare e
respirare sostituisce il verbo parlare
con il perno respirare e ancora dice
vuole ch'io respiri a te che ti diletti
di sé ebbene quel ch'io respiri a te si
intende che io vi racconti che io balli
a tema questo proprio per sottolineare
che il respiro è parte integrante della
comunicazione e del nostro rivolgerci al
mondo la parola è possibile solo grazie
al respiro la comunicazione al centro e
andate ancora sia presente per esempio
quello fatto dalla vita nuova
laddove danni
proprio il topos si dice letteratura
dell'innamorato cioè un modo preciso di
essere degli innamorati letteratura
solitamente letteratura l'innamorato
impallidisce la vista dell'amante oppure
non può fare a meno che
sospirare ed è quello che ci racconta
abitante quando dice quelli che la hanno
comprende hanno accesso a destra aden
tanto che gli dice non sapeva né alcuno
entrano quale potesse attirare che del
principio o non venisse
sospirato
e ancora ballerini dice la dinamica
flussi smarrita che sospirando dice a
nel pensiero
pensate a quante volte
pensando sospirate i sospiri il respiro
che si fa sospiro vai frammentarsi ai
vostri pensieri
si si pensa spesso sospirando e dante
dice ancora
rispose in voce con sospiri nista il
respiro ci fa sospiro eva inframmezzati
anche alla voce sono tutte
sottolineature che probabilmente nel
quotidiano non notiamo ma sono
importanti
dando importanza al nostro respiro ma
ciò che siamo ciò che riuscì a mora a
emettere a comunicare all'altro in
quello che è il linguaggio paraverbale e
dante nel 1300 lo sapeva bene avete
visto abbiamo
percorso respiro che da un modo di dire
è diventato un modo di dire del 1300 poi
è diventato il respiro di un naufrago
adesso è il respiro di un innamorato e
addirittura si è andato a sostituire al
verbo parlare
e infine potevamo concludere quello che
questo nostro intervento con quello che
forse è il sonetto più conosciuto
mandiamo anche dei più belli della
terrieri che è tanto gentile e tanto
onesta pare nella prima no ma
sicuramente ha detto tante volte si
studia a scuola e pensate come si chiude
si chiude con questi tre persi dice eva
che la sua rabbia che della sua l'abbia
si muova uno spirito sua le piene
d'amore che va dicendo allarma
sospira
[Musica]
ed è proprio con questo augurio che
vogliamo salutarlo con l'idea che possa
in qualche modo respirare più soltanto
ma che possa respirare anche proprio
come diceva che va dicendo all'anima
sospira cosa sostiene che è stato anche
la mostra di sé per farlo come sempre ci
viene sicuramente d'aiuto la polizia
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]